make some cotton bales with her which
she sells it for a small fortune
so she was good with money and she
spends most of the rest of the war in
New York City with her mother and her
very pro-union brother which created
great tension in the house and at the
end when Lincoln was assassinated there
were rumours in New York that there was
a Confederate flag on display in her
house in Staten Island and some people
broke into the house but I don't think
they found a flag but she was resilient
and she loved Washington DC and the
story that illustrates this which I was
delighted to find and my research during
the peace conference she wrote her
mother oh of course I have to get back
to the plantation be with the children
and a few four or five days later I
found a newspaper article saying she had
been spotted dancing late in the night
at the Brown's hotel no mention of her
husband so she loved Washington a social
life she comes back to Washington
she reestablishes herself as a former
first lady she befriends other first
ladies mrs. grant
and Mrs Hayes her portrait is put in the
White House and she gets a pension from
Congress and she sends her daughter to
the convent school at Georgetown which
so impress her she converts to a Roman
Catholicism it's received through the
church by the Bishop of Baltimore and
she later before she dies moves to
Richmond and dies there so what happens
to her and her husband sort of embodies
the vast transformation that the country
went through before and after the Peace
Conference
they're on their their plantation with
their scores of slaves and their
carriage with the coachman and livery
and even had a river barge that had the
Sherwood Forest logo which was a bow and
arrow painted on it and the slave
oarsmen had a special blue uniforms with
the bow and arrow and blazoned on it so
they lived really like Cleopatra going
up and down the James River like
Cleopatra went up and down went up and
down the River Nile quite regal in that
whole world of course was over not very
long after the Washington peace
conference and that's one reason why I
think the story is so interesting it
gives us sort of a last chance a last
opportunity to that window of a pre-war
America
who the people were without the
assumptions were what the debates were
and that's our last chance to see those
people because they're all virtually
gone with the wind just within a few
months and after they adjourned so thank
you for your patience are listening and
let me take your questions if you have
any yes ma'am
states representing and I'm curious that
after they seceded I mean what did all
the Senators they're no communication
with them anymore and in some way to get
them talking seceded states I mentioned
Jefferson Davis for example and left in
late January and many of them gave
dramatic farewell speeches in the Senate
or in the house so the deep south did
not participate in the peace conference
the upper south North Carolina Tennessee
Virginia Chris Kentucky they were there
Missouri was there so the hope was if
they could breach them acceptable
accommodations of the slavery in the
South that the deep south might be lured
back into the Union
that they could have taken back even
what they offered which was to encode
slavery into the Constitution in
perpetuity and in fact the proposal
actually declared that all of these
other proposals could not be revoked
except by unanimous consent of all the
states so literally it was it would be
impossible to change to run delete them
from the Constitution in the future so
slavery potentially could have existed
for decades more had that gotten through
but the deep south was no longer
interested and even that kind of
compromise and the only time John Tyler
spoke during the convention when he left
the dais and addressed the debate he
wanted presidential appointments to the
territorial governments to have to have
approval in the Senate by a majority of
the slave states and the non slave state
so in the South in essence the Senate
would have to be divided into two
different houses to ensure that no one -
anti-slavery would ever be appointed -
territorial governor out in the West and
that was voted down yes sir you
mentioned that John Tyler had married a
very young woman some years back that
was at the Blenheim house and I was
talking to an author and he told me that
the grandson the youngest grandson of
John Tyler we still have I have you
heard anything yes my great hope and
researching writing this book was it
would be that I would have an excuse to
go see the grandson who still owns a
Sherwood Forest there are two grandsons
still alive because John Tyler had
children up until he was still 70 and he
had a son who had children in his 70s so
he has two grandchildren lives were born
in the 1920s one of them is in Tennessee
and one so owns Sherwood Forest I think
he lives part time in Richmond so I
thought surely I could get a meeting
with him I've seen him on c-span and
I've heard him in fact early this year
Associated Press found out he was still
alive and interviewed him and he
mentioned well people dismissed my
grandfather but he did have this
Washington peace conference that tried
to avert the Civil War but when I called
sherwoodforest they said that his health
was declining and he wasn't available to
be met
however every time I called the local
public library for information whoever
answered the phone would always say oh
yeah he's my cousin and I just saw him
at the restaurant last week so evidently
I need to go down to that restaurant in
Charles City Virginia and tried to meet
him
but I haven't succeeded at that yet that
sounds correct yes I think you're great
yes did any of the proposals get
approved that the south the southern
states were hoping for no this whole a
package that came out of the Washington
Peace Conference it was voted down
overwhelmingly in the Senate and didn't
even come to a vote in the house I think
one or two state legislators may have
voted on them but at that point it was
too late and of no point since itself
did they vote on it or they just came up
with proposals yes I kind of in each at
the time I kind of skipped over that
crucial part I'll leave it to you to to
read the book they did go through this
dramatic vote on Tuesday that last
Tuesday in February and everyone just
assumed well it went to this committee
where all the states represented so it
was just sort of an of course they'll go
through but the most contentious one was
about the allowing slavery into the the
territories and it's a they voted not by
individuals but by States and it failed
by one vote and everyone literally
gasped what's happened we never expected
this and they adjourned immediately so
you can just imagine all the near panic
and the hallways of the Willard hotel
and the last slots of negotiations going
on that night and there may have been a
meeting with Lincoln that night by some
of the delegates is unclear whether it
was that night or than the next night
but the next day they vote on it and
clearly it had been arranged at this
time it passed by one vote in Illinois
switched from I think abstention to four
so some of the Republicans in Illinois
switched and so did Lincoln encouraged
them to do that probably not because one
of them later sort of apologetically
told Lincoln I guess my career is over
but he didn't take it that hard and
Lincoln's secretary John Hay later
dismissively said well at least the
Peace Conference didn't do any great
damage so I think they were kind of
relieved that it was
yes states that paid the way and the
Willard brothers gave them the space the
meeting space for free at least a
conference space not their hotel rooms
and including and included in that
package was a free lighting so I guess
the gas lights were expensive and that
was kind of a special thing to get free
lighting yes that's all they talked
about so sometimes when people say well
all these other issues were in play over
the Civil War and over secession well as
far as the Peace Conference was
concerned for three and a half weeks
that's all they talked about was slavery
some people have said that the tariff
was an issue in the Civil War but it
never came up in the case conference
when he gets the salute do you think
that they actually thought they were
making progress through the war was the
mood
they knew that this was a dead end I
think the northern Republicans just
wanted to prevent any damage from being
done and salmon tastes kept making
emotions they adjourn and reconvene
after the inauguration they decided
stalling for time I think most of the
people there genuinely wanted an
agreement especially they are the older
statesman who to their credit they had
held the country together for several
decades and but and they just assumed
they could do it again but they had no
more tricks left in their bag and also
the fact that these those old men who
were still alive at this point are sort
of the second tier of pre-war leadership
so they're really great figures like
Daniel Webster and Henry Clay died five
or six years before so these individuals
just no longer had the capacity plus the
country was far more polarized now than
it had been five or six years before
anybody else I'm getting what is
question so many give you want so what
if the thirteenth amendment had
enshrined slavery rather than polished
it what would have the next 50 years
look like yeah that's uh maybe you can
write a book on that John has written a
wonderful book on the Year 1844 and it
would blurb my book very generously so
yes if slavery were actually encoded
into the Constitution and were no
possibility of picking it out presumably
slavery would have survived for decades
longer and less some miraculous new
national consensus emerged against it
but I don't know where that would have
taken place and it's remarkable that and
going to the speeches of the Peace
Convention the number of northerners who
were resentful over the abolitionists
and the Republican Party and Lincoln and
were very adamant that slavery was none
of the business of the north it was a
hands-off approach and of course
Buchanan himself famously after his
inauguration when the Dred Scott
decision was released said oh the
slavery issue has finally been put to
rest and settled once and for all
hahaha yes was it actually called the
peace
at the time and secondly was there any
sense at the conference of an effort to
just was a primarily just to keep the
Union together or was there a strong
sense of or on the edge of the Cataclysm
that we the newspapers that alternate
between called calling it the peace
conference or the peace convention not
much difference sometimes the old
gentleman's convention in terms of were
they aware of the Cataclysm to come
there were many speeches where they
would use the phrase rivers of blood
rivers of blood rivers of blood so at
least theoretically they knew there
could be a great catastrophe but it's
hard to believe they could imagine that
700,000 were going to die in the next
four years which would be like seven
million today in four years in terms of
percentage of population but I've
wondered as John Tyler broke the train
from Richmond up to Washington he went
through so many of the Great
battlefields of the next four years and
as a former president and
commander-in-chief he must have realized
that yes this is where the war is gonna
take place if we fail so there must have
been a great sense of responsibility
anybody else
anyone want to grab c-span's attention
with something outrageous every other
not well thank you so much and please I
get a copy of my book if it's available
outside
yes mark absolutely like to add you are
a genius and you're very talented
Oh like that's a perfect conclusion to
my talk thank you for coming
[Applause]
our author today is Angela Polly Hudson
who is an associate and soon to be full
professor at Texas A&M University she's
an expert in American Indian history
19th century u.s. south and
representations of American Indians in
pop culture as well as the intersection
of American Indian and African American
lives
Hudson received her PhD from Yale in
2007 and has held fellowships at the
Newberry Library the American
Philosophical Society and the by Nicki
Rare Book and Manuscript library among
others her first book was called Creek
paths and federal roads Indian settlers
and slaves and the making of the
American South published in 2010 and her
most recent book which is the subject of
her talk today is real native genius how
an ex-slave and a white Mormon became
famous Indians which is just published
from the University of North Carolina
press angela is a dear friend and
occasional mentor to me
I'll dispense with any embarrassing
stories and just say that it's an honor
and a pleasure to welcome here today so
please join me
[Applause]
thanks Joe for that introduction and
thank you for coming this morning I'm
gonna tell you a story today about real
native genius of two of them actually
and like most stories it's both
unbelievable and I think highly
entertaining interwoven with it our
strands of many other stories and like
many stories there are lots of places
where one can begin so naturally I'm
going to start in the middle in 1852 a
40-something white woman named Sarah
Marlatt pressed charges against her
Indian husband for bigamy
Marlatt a white woman from Medina New
York had met her beau on a canal boat in
the summer of 1851 and married him after
a courtship of only a few days but her
new husband known to audiences across
the region as the virtuosic Choctaw
flutist oka tubby already had an Indian
wife and family even more shocking was
the discovery that marlott tawny lovers
the papers put it was no Indian at all
rumors began to spread that the
well-known performer was actually a
Negro barber who had managed to humbug
his way across the United States
performing his Indian show for
unsuspecting audiences from Missouri to
New Hampshire like other penny press
celebrities the salacious stories kept
Antebellum newspaper readers both
titillated and horrified oka taboos
charade made great copy and he became
something of a tabloid sensation as
dramatic as this case seems the brief
affair between oka tubby and Sarah
Marlatt was just another episode in the
thrilling life of the man from Natchez
Mississippi alternately known as Warner
Meharry William Meharry William Carey
William chubby William McGuffey polka
tubby and dr. okay he had been born into
slavery in in Mississippi and became the
property of his free blacks
half-siblings when his owner died so let
that sink in for a moment
he's born into slavery and he becomes
the property of his own free black half
siblings when
owner died he was mostly hired in and
worked at a variety of trades sometime
in his youth he began to play music and
found he had an exceptional natural
talent as a performer in time he became
a militia pfeiffer a celebrated flute
player a riverboat confidence man a
Mormon laminate prophet a cult leader an
Indian chief an attraction in PT
Barnum's Museum a temperance activist
ventriloquist a freemason a medicine man
and an international fugitive his
companion from 1846 onward was Lucille
or Lucy Staunton although she like her
husband professed to be descended from
native royalty often performing as the
Mohawk princess lost zeal mana toy
alotta be she was in fact a white Mormon
divorcee with three children together
they crafted an elaborate traveling
Indian act that included a short-lived
but fanatical religious sect a variety
of musical stage shows a medical
business and three editions of their
composite autobiography their
professional Indian personas helped
conceal their interracial relationship
as well as many other secrets they may
have wished to hide like their
unorthodox religious beliefs and marital
practices they carved out alternate
lives for themselves capitalizing on but
simultaneously reinforcing Antebellum
beliefs about American Indians the
emancipatory potential of their Indian
act was compromised however by the
narrowness of the stereotypes on which
it relied in other words while their
pretended identities may have liberated
them from some of the narrow categories
that confined them they weren't doing
American Indians any favours now many
people have never heard of oka tubby or
his wife Lucille and if it weren't for
the work of historian Daniel Littlefield
jr. who edited annotated and republished
their autobiography in 1988 even fewer
people would recognize their names what
little scholarship exists on the Natchez
native and his wife tends to make one or
more of these claims first that tubby
was a fugitive slave who claimed Indian
ancestry to attain his freedom
second that while tubby perhaps wasn't
an Indian as he claimed his wife
certainly was and third that they are
responsible for the ban on blacks in the
Mormon priesthood that was not lifted
until 1978 all of these claims are wrong
sort of so the first most common and
wrong claim about okay tubby is that he
was a fugitive slave who used claims of
Indian ancestry to escape bondage
okay that he claimed to be Native
American in order to become free now
since there was considerable
intermixture between indigenous African
and European people in the Mississippi
River Valley and in fact throughout the
early South it's certainly possible that
he had Choctaw ancestry but the truth of
the matter is that it's both totally
unknowable and in my opinion irrelevant
Choctaw folks might have rejected his
claims anyway since he insisted that his
Choctaw ancestry came from his father
mashaallah tubby and Choctaw ancestry
historically operates on the logic of
matrilineal ax T figuring kinship in
other words through mother's not
father's while Indian ancestry was
sometimes used by enslaved people in the
19th century to sue for their freedom
this view of oka Tubby's life is not
just too narrow it's wrong although born
a slave and slated to remain there by
his owners last will by age 33
oka tubby then known as Warner Meharry
was already a free man manumitted by his
half-brother / owner whose name is Bob
by the time he was freed he had already
come to appreciate the anonymity that
river boats and port cities afforded and
the flute-playing vagabond began to
travel beyond his hometown of Natchez
along the Mississippi River the Missouri
River the Ohio River moving from New
Orleans to st. Louis to Louisville and
beyond playing in ballrooms staterooms
and saloons these sojourned ultimately
brought him to Illinois where in 1846 he
married Mormon divorcee
Lucy Stanton sometime in this period but
after becoming free he began to use an
Indian
and identity and while he did assume a
variety of students costumes and
disguises over his career if his
strategy was to lay low he did a
miserable job of it from the moment he
left Natchez he consistently thrust
himself into the spotlight so this idea
this claim that he was in fact a
fugitive slave who was trying to mask
his identity in order to attain his
freedom is fairly debunked whether he
was advertising his skills as a musician
for hire in New Orleans
stealing himself to white women at the
Mormons winter quarters or taking the
stage at popular antebellum venues like
carisi's saloon in Washington DC or
Castle Garden in New York excitement and
publicity followed him around with time
and a little help from patrons and
scheming managers he became practiced in
the art of self fashioning or what one
scholar calls theatrical selfhood
but I'll come back to all that the
second most common and wrong claim about
the people at the center of this book is
that while Okeechobee may or may not
have been American Indian his wife
certainly was with the exception of
Mormon scholars extant historical and
literary studies uniformly described la
Seal Manito a lot tubby as Delaware and
Mohawk as she consistently claimed or
usually just Delaware or Lenape despite
the absence of evidence for these claims
some scholars have even crafted
elaborate arguments based on
presumptions of her identity her Indian
identity while it's possible as I've
suggested that Okeechobee might have had
indigenous forebears as the multi-ethnic
history of Natchez suggests la Steel aka
Lucy Stanton was not the Indian princess
she claimed to be born in western New
York in 1817 by the time she was a
teenager
Lucy Stanton had moved with her family
to the southern shore of Lake Erie to
the community of Kirtland Ohio and in
1830 they converted to a new Mormon
religion brought by missionaries from
New York the missionaries had been sent
by Prophet Joseph Smith and were on
their way west to preach the new gospel
to the people they called the Lamanites
the term they used for American Indians
now while a variety of early national
religious
denominations were interested in
American Indians largely as potential
converts one thing that set the early
Mormon Knights as they were sometimes
called apart was the centrality of
American Indians to their religious
doctrines their centrality to their in
their theology in fact the Book of
Mormon identifies indigenous Americans
as descendants of the Lamanites a
dark-skinned and degraded ancient people
scattered across North America who
although although they were unbelievers
were nevertheless capable of future
Redemption and therefore marked for
special attention as diasporic and
persecuted peoples Native Americans may
have been considered even a sort of
spiritual kin by some early Mormons
including Lucy Stanton who were
themselves facing violence and forced
migration for their religious beliefs it
seems likely that Meharry aka oka tubby
and Stanton
lost seal first met in Quincy Illinois
where she and her three young children
lived alongside her parents following
her divorce from ex-mormon Oliver
Bassett after the Stanton family
converted to Mormonism they had migrated
to Missouri with other Latter day Saints
but were expelled during the racially
charged mormon war of 1838 they then
settled in Quincy just downriver from
Nauvoo which would become the Mormon
metropolis despite the fact that Mormon
immigrants were among the beneficiaries
of Indian Removal living on land
recently cleansed of its indigenous
inhabitants Mormon persecution and
flight during this era interestingly
mirrors the forced removal of American
Indians although they tended to be
forced in opposite directions the
Cherokee Trail of Tears is crossing the
Mississippi going west in the winter of
1838 the Mormons are being forced across
the Mississippi River east in the winter
of 1830
from the time they united in the mid
1840s Stanton and Meharry collaborated
to cultivate a particular public image
he presented himself as two Mormon
elders as a lamb a night prophet and the
pair were sealed that is married for
eternity in the Mormon temple at navoo
although she was not yet claiming to be
Delaware she had already distinguished
herself as someone who had a peculiar
fascination with Indians as a youth in
Ohio she and her sisters along with
another of a number of other early
Mormon converts mostly women used to get
the power as they put it they would ride
on the floor speak in tongues which they
referred to as speaking engine she was
drawn to Indian this through both her
own faith and probably through the
romanticized depiction of Native people
in the popular fiction of the day when
she met this Choctaw flutist who claimed
he had received prophecies about
bringing the Lamanites to Christ she
found him irresistible but her own
performance as the Delaware princess was
just that a performance despite the fact
that she was never outed during her
lifetime and that scholars as recently
as a decade ago we're still writing
books and articles based on the belief
that she was in fact a Delaware woman
lawsy Oh Lord Lucy Stanton would later
have one child with ocut uh be a son
they named mashaallah which was a very
clever way to connect him to the man he
claimed as his father their son now
named mu Sheila tubby after his
purported grandfather Marshall a tubby
he appeared onstage with them in a
pint-sized Indian costume from time to
time but she also had three children
from her first marriage to Mormon
pioneer Oliver Bassett Solon was 12
Seraphin Ann was 9 and Samara was 8 when
their mother married oka tubby at that
time known as William Meharry in nabu 4
years later when they hit the road for
an Eastern tour she left those children
her older children in the care of her
parents she would not see them again for
19 years
the third predominant and only slightly
wrong story line about oka tubby and la
seal is that their time among the Saints
among the Mormons before they embarked
on their national tour was largely
responsible for the ban on blacks in the
Mormon priesthood which as I've
mentioned was not rescinded or removed
until 1978 scholars of Mormon history
discussed the man known among them as
William Meharry as a quote half Indian
half Negro prophet who impressed Brigham
Young with his musical abilities when he
and his wife joined other Mormons at the
temporary encampment known as winter
quarters just before the great westward
migration to Salt Lake Valley he was
alleged to have led followers away and
into a secretive schismatic sect white
female members of this sect were
supposed to have had sex with the
Lamanite prophet no fewer than three
times each during the day and in a room
with his wife present in order to fully
seal them to his prophetic eminence when
the unorthodox nature unorthodox I
supposed to put it mildly nature of
their little movement was revealed and
white women aged 16 to 60 came forward
to admit that they had slept with the
Indian pretender while his wife looked
on the couple was run out of town at
gunpoint now much about this particular
storyline is true but there are two
things that are wrong with it first is
that it suggests that the priesthood ban
was largely the result of the
misbehavior of one person not
attributable to an undercurrent of white
supremacy in Mormon thinking but it also
claims that the Mormons were certain
that he was black and not Indian and
they were not certain of this my
research suggests that his entree into
the Mormon Church was based in part on
the widespread notion that he was or at
least could have been American Indian my
my studies also show that Lucy Stanton
was not only not his victim which this
particular line of thinking likes to
sort of portray she was his
co-conspirator helping to shape not only
his rise as a lamb a night prophet but
his subsequent musical and medical
careers as well
so by the end of 1847 Macario was
performing in Baltimore in Washington DC
as mr. chubby a Choctaw flute is torn
from his tribe when a boy but now able
to trace his origin as the descendant of
one of its Chiefs a storyline possibly
borrowed from William Gilmore Simms
popular 1841 tale called
oka tibi or the Choctaw Samson Lucy
Stanton now using the name law seal
played a growing role in shaping their
Indian show including the production of
the first edition of their autobiography
a thrilling sketch of the life of the
distinguished chief ouka tubby alias
William chubby son of the head chief
mashaallah tubby of the Choctaw Nation
of Indians published in 1848 for about a
year they were the talk of the town on
the East Coast Okeechobee and his wife
performed at notable venues including
the Chinese Theater in Philadelphia and
even did a stint at PT Barnum's American
Museum in New York from late 1847 until
early 18-49 they appeared at most of the
major theatres in the East including
Castle Garden off the tip of Manhattan
Island they presented Indian concerts
lectures on the plight of the red man
and occasionally offered medical advice
he wore an elaborate Indian costume of
buckskin fringe feathers and jewelry and
she appeared by his side as a
Christianized Indian maiden they basked
in the brief glow of the limelight and
they succeeded in their performances in
part because the figure of the Indian
was as one scholar put it sufficiently
remote from the spectators everyday life
particularly on the East Coast to permit
the dramatists to spread the aura of
romance around him but familiar enough
to be rendered convincingly beyond just
a means of income performing his Indian
also allowed them to conceal their
ascribed racial identities and their
complicated past as a former slave and
an apostate Mormon and I think they
liked it
but their fortunes shifted when they
returned to Missouri in mid 18-49 facing
financial hardship after reuniting with
her older children and assaults from
white and Indian neighbors who
alternately accused them of crimes and
committed crimes against them the
Tubby's headed east again in 1850 and
remade themselves once more as purveyors
of real Indian medicine that's how they
advertised it as they traveled through
the Ohio Valley
dr. oka tubby as he was now known and
his wife stopped to treat patients and
occasionally take the stage but it was
not a fortuitous time to be a person of
indeterminate race traveling across the
United States The Fugitive Slave Act
passed in September 1850 codifying the
EM ability of slaves and threatening
three people of color with kidnapping
for many endangered by the law it was a
final catalyst for flight and they made
their way to Canada
before long the Tubby's would also be in
Canada settling in the heart of Toronto
but fear of racial persecution was only
one reason that they fled the states
during this same period Okeechobee was
the subject of a startling expose in the
United States newspapers in June 1851 a
Louisville Kentucky paper published a
story claiming that the Choctaw flutist
and Indian doctor was in fact not
American Indian but a black man many
southern and western papers followed
suit each adding fuel to the flames by
including personal knowledge of his
earlier life in Natchez New Orleans st.
Louis and Louisville
and poking a great deal of fun at
dim-witted northerners who flocked to
his performances under the delusion that
he was an Indian a Yankee they
maintained couldn't tell and asked from
an elbow or in this case an Indian from
a Negro the tone of these initial
revelations however was surprisingly
mild and emphasized the humorous nature
of what they called his humbug rather
than its potential dangers word of
Tubby's purported real identity was slow
to emerge in the northern press where he
had and his wife had been the darling of
audiences for some time but by midsummer
1851 word began to spread and it showed
up in newspaper
New York Connecticut New Hampshire
Massachusetts in Maine in the midst of
the rising controversy Okeechobee did
something remarkable he took another
wife a white woman named Sarah marlott
who we've already met area newspapers
carried word of the nuptials that took
place next to the roaring cataracts of
Niagara Falls and highlighted the fact
that the self-proclaimed Choctaw already
had an Indian wife one early response
came from a Buffalo nyan who wrote to
the city's newspaper that while much was
said about women's rights I do not
believe one woman has a right to marry
another woman's husband stories about
oka Tubby's bigamous marriage to sarah
marlin were then fused to expose x'
about his purportedly true racial
identity the once famous Indian
performer was now called a notorious
scoundrel although audiences might have
suspected earlier that he was perhaps
not exactly who he said he was his
ability to dupe a white woman into
marrying him rendered him now a
dangerous character just as in the
winter quarters controversy the specter
of a black man seducing white women was
too much for many Antebellum Americans
to bear interestingly however the
unmasking of Okeechobee as an ex-slave
of possible African ancestry and a
master of humbug who rivaled Barnum
effectively obscured the truth about
lost seals or Lucy Stanton's background
even when Sarah Marlatt brought suit
against hubby for bigamy in 1852 and the
details of their romance were trotted
out in a Toronto courtroom law seal was
always depicted as a long-suffering
[ __ ] just one more victim of the
two-timing black confidence man although
the bigamy charges were dropped
partially because no one could prove
that the original marriage was legal and
also because bigamy was at that time not
an extraditable offense between the
United States and Canada
the Tubby's new life in Toronto was not
an easy one
besides Marla's case public assertions
of malpractice plagued them in an effort
to counter the mountain of accusations
stacking up against them in their
medical practice they published a final
edition of their autobiography in late
1852 its primary purpose like that of
this broadside was to reiterate claims
to Indian Asst and assert his
qualifications as an Indian doctor which
had become their primary source of
income
since the stage shows their stage shows
had ended again little or no scrutiny
was directed towards La Steel and behind
the scenes she had meanwhile managed to
assume the primary role in their medical
practice
apparently specializing in treating
women's ailments after 1856 records on
oka tubby are scarce frustratingly but
perhaps fittingly given the wild twists
and turns of his life he simply
disappears la Steel now known as an
Indian doctress in her own right however
carried on in 1862 as the civil war was
unfolding Madame la Co as the the name
she was using at the time Madame la
Steel was arrested for manslaughter in
Buffalo New York not far from her
birthplace the Indian doctress as she
was known was suspected of running an
illegal abortion practice the Buffalo
courier was the first to report on what
they called a human slaughterhouse
discovered on the corner of Washington
and Carroll streets across from the
prominent Bonney House Hotel and just
steps from the Buffalo Waterfront on
Thursday June 5th 1862 police learned
that a hearse had suspiciously parked in
front of the Indian doctor says
residents which was also her business
after the cart bore away a body they
contacted the local of other local
authorities
the victim was Nyami Hamilton 29 year
old married mother of three from Genesee
County New York her estranged husband
was fighting for the Union Army and she
had been brought to the Indian doctress
allegedly to procure an abortion
by a Michigan man purporting to be her
uncle but the rumors suggested was
undoubtedly her paramour convinced after
examining the corpse that something was
amiss police returned to the home of
Madame la seal with a search warrant and
inside they found two more desperately
ill young women one of whom
maria luisa buyer would die within the
day also from an apparent abortion
attempt Western New York papers eagerly
seized on the salacious details of this
story and alleged that the Indian wretch
had been running a slaughterhouse for
aborto reham it's an interesting
neologism the abort her IAM she faced
persecution not only in the press and
from local law enforcement but also from
medical professionals in the area who
were busily trying to rid their
profession of both Indian doctors and
women practitioners in Madame Lhasa the
anxieties about so-called quack doctors
converged with rising concern over
women's reproductive control and she was
vilified as representing the dangers of
both convicted of manslaughter
she spent seven years at hard labor in
Sing Sing but at no point in the
investigation or her subsequent
incarceration was her Indian identity
questioned
so the underlying question that drove my
research was why what would drive compel
or inspire a free black southern man and
a divorced white Mormon woman to become
Indians for protection for profit I
think sometimes for pleasure it helps to
reveal a central paradox in American
attitudes during the antebellum period
about identity itself on the one hand
broad social changes attributable to the
market revolution inspired a belief in
the flexibility even the fluidity of
individual identities such beliefs
underlay the contemporaneous fascination
with both self fashioning and public
performance the antebellum period was
the era of humbug of confidence men and
painted women of blackface minstrel zand
feejee mermaids but such openness to
performance and representation also
spawned fear the passage of the Fugitive
Slave Law provides a handy barometer of
this anxiety it rested on the logic of
racial recognition and reinforced a
widespread concern that people were
passing for something they were not the
rise in what is termed scientific racism
in this very era demonstrates the
paradox at a time when audiences flocked
to theaters every night to be fooled by
white men wearing blackface scientific
men were busy measuring and codifying
the differences of the races and
insisting not on the fluidity of
identity but on its fixity examining the
lives of Okeechobee and la Steel I think
lays bare both of these impulses I argue
that this inventive pair capitalized on
the category of the Indian still very
much in flux during mid-century as a
sort of escape hatch from these
contradictory impulses towards fluid and
fixed identities in the world around
them and I think their choices reveal
both the currency and the flexibility of
the Indian as a signifier Indian this in
the mid 19th century was a wide-ranging
set of ideas about how native people
looked talked lived and loved the period
between Indian removal of the 1830s and
the
the war was arguably the most generative
in American history with regard to the
popular representation of American
Indians these representations took many
forms and had many sources including
importantly the performances of Native
people themselves as diplomats orders
writers and artists oka tubby and la
Steel drew on this deep well of
Indianness and exploited their audiences
fascination with Indians most often to
make money but also to conceal as I've
suggested they're highly controversial
mixed-race marriage behind their schemes
it's clear that they too were fascinated
even seduced by the idea of the Indian
now scholarly considerations of
performing Indian Asoka ston a practice
known as playing Indians sort of the
most commonly known as playing Indian
this is a phenomenon wherein primarily
non-native people imagine create and Don
Indian costumes and engage in real or
imagined Indian activities scholar Reina
Greene calls it one of the oldest and
most pervasive forms of American
cultural expression with a few notable
exceptions these analyses this
scholarship on playing Indian has
focused on white men who dawn Indian
outfits costumes and activities for a
variety of social cultural and political
reasons from the Sons of Liberty at
Boston Harbor dressing as Mohawks to
Dumpty in the harbor to the Boy Scouts
and Halloween costumes of today because
they do not conform to our expectations
about who plays Indian and why oka Tubby
as an ex-slave
and las geel as a white Mormon woman
complicate our ideas about the
performative uses of Indian asst even as
their pretensions underscore the
centrality of the Indian to shaping
American identities in addition to
concerns about passing and posing and
emergent practices of playing Indian
public debates about identity and
imposture in the antebellum period were
frequently in brocaded with concerns
about faith and religion the market
revolution coincided with the tail end
of the Second Great Awakening an era
that historians Paul Johnson and Shaw
melenz have called years of intense
religious excitement and sectarian
invention this was a time when profits
rose from the unlikeliest of quarters to
proclaim their revelations and exhort
followers to join various churches
quests missions and revolutions
Mormonism was but one of these inventive
movements and the degree to which
founder Joseph Smith was depicted as a
charlatan confidence man and dangerous
seducer and women offers striking
parallels to how oka tubby was
ultimately regarded I argue that's what
what is most important about Okita be in
law co and their Indian Asst is how and
why they constructed and performed
alternative personas that allowed them
to transcend their prescribed identities
while also capitalizing often quite
literally on popular cultural beliefs
about what it meant to be an Indian
their actions may have subverted some
discourses of race and gender but they
emphatically endorsed others as cultural
studies scholar George Lipsitz maintains
images in negotiation with power are
often ambiguous complicated and
implicated in the crimes they seek to
address
so not all questions about the
extraordinary lives of Okeechobee and la
Ciel can be satisfactorily answered but
it's perhaps fitting that some mystery
remains after all the pair went to great
lengths to disguise or shroud or alter
the circumstances of their lives their
backgrounds and some of their efforts
remain successful to this day these
uncertainties while frustrating to the
reader and trust me absolutely maddening
to the historian must nevertheless
remain but stories must have endings
even if there are unsatisfied ones so
after she was released from prison in
1869 las geel turned up in Utah I like
to think she took the newly completed
Transcontinental Railroad that's
probably not true but I like to imagine
that she did although her son Missoula
the child that she had with Agata B was
nowhere to be found
in Utah she was reunited with her
daughter Samira now grown with five
children of her own the next few years
were bittersweet once more using her
birth name Lucy Stanton she was also
reunited with her other daughter Ann and
her son sullen who had been estranged
from the family for a number of years
sadly within the space of another two
years and Solon and Lucy Stanton's
father Daniel all died in March 1873 at
age 57
Lucy Stanton the brother married the
brother of her first husband Oliver and
again became a Bassett so she had been
Lucy Stanton Bassett before she was lost
seal tubby she becomes again Lucy
Stanton Bassett at the end of her life
by marrying the brother of her first
husband she began to work as a midwife
did her Mormon friends in Utah know
about her experiences in the 20-plus
years since she had seen them surely
some of them had read the news of oka
Tubby's escapades or at least seen
notice of his apparent bigamy in the
Deseret News two decades before and yes
the news had spread that far when he
married Sarah Marley itand I have Sarah
Marlin at Niagara Falls the news was
carried in the desert at paper and
desert newspaper all the way in Utah
interestingly her time in Springville
where she had settled in Utah likely
brought her back into contact with some
of her disgraced former followers from
the winter quarters episode for instance
Sisson chase his wife had astonished him
into temporary mutinous with her
description of the Indian prophet sexual
sealing ceremony was now an elder in the
Springville ward whether or not these
individuals had forgiven Luci Stanton
for her part in that scandal is
difficult to say her marriage to him and
Bassett the brother of her first husband
might have also raised eyebrows both
because he had been excommunicated from
the church and because at the time he
married her he also had a wife and
children in California maybe her
daughter's Samira's status in the town
helped shield her from scrutiny Samara
would formerly Basset had been among the
earliest Mormon settlers in the area and
she was married to Lyman wood the son of
a prosperous businessman and the mayor
of Springville perhaps unknowingly
following in her mother's theatrical
footsteps she had also become known for
promoting musical entertainments in the
frontier town when her brother-in-law
turned third husband left her in 1876
and then died while traveling to
Philadelphia Lucy Stanton Bassett was
once more a woman alone perhaps seeking
the support of the church she was
rebaptised and reconfirmed as a member
of the Latter day Saints Church her
reentry into the fold was complete but
she was not well she suffered from
intermittent bouts of paralysis probably
brought on by advanced diabetes and
finally died after a long bout with the
ailment in 1878 Lucy celesta Stanton
basset AKA la Steele Manito alotta B aka
Madame la Steele is buried in the city
cemetery in Springville Utah next two
members of her family
among the other grandchildren who paid
their respects at grandmother Lucy's
funeral may have stood Samira's adopted
son Frank a Paiute Indian perhaps to
rescue him from a life of bondage
Samira's husband purchased Frank from
the Utes during a mission to the
Lamanites and brought him home standing
at her grave in the looming shadow of
the Wasatch Mountains the young Indian
man would have been nearly the same age
as her mysteriously absent son mashella
one can only wonder what he knew about
the extraordinary life of his
grandmother as a famous Indian or her
tumultuous marriage to a man who like
himself had started life as a slave
thank you
[Applause]
so I'm happy to take questions
yes
how buried was the evidence that you use
to retell the story was it something
that the story just overlooked or did it
take a lot of digging that's a great
question
most of the evidence was not varied
buried deep very deeply one of the
interesting things that happened is I
discovered that there were and this is
part of why I sort of organized the talk
around this idea of things we thought we
know about these people that turned out
to be sort of wrong there had actually
been a good deal of scholarly attention
paid to them but one of the things that
happens I think particularly was until
very recently with Mormon history is
that it exists sort of alongside other
avenues and subfields of American
history you know a lot of folks who are
trained in US history don't ever really
think about looking in Mormon
historiography so so a lot of that stuff
on the the Mormon side of things was
very well known but they didn't know
that William Meharry was necessarily oka
tubby whereas if you study
african-american literature for example
you know who oka tubby is because it's
one of the important autobiographies of
the 19th century but you may have no
idea and scholars had no idea that his
wife was not in fact a Delaware woman
she was a white Mormon so so in many
ways it was actually just about uniting
streams of evidence that were relatively
apparent and trying to weave them
together to tell a sort of coherent
story
yes form there so no one foot led man if
you know or just have a suspicion of
this and Wow his crowds to sort of yes
as well yeah so I talked about this in
the book a little bit that I that it's
possible that the people who paid to see
oka tubby at Barnum's Museum were in
fact in on the joke as you might say
right they kind of got it and that part
of what they were paying to see with the
spectacle of this obviously to them man
of African descent in all of his
tinkling G jaws is one of the words the
phrases they used to describe him all of
his costuming and performing his musical
act it's unclear
Barnum doesn't really talk about him he
also interacted with Solomon Smith old
Saul who was a really famous sort of
theatre promoter in the 19th century who
does write about him and talk about him
in his own memoirs and is very candid
about we all knew he wasn't Indian but
it was entertaining nonetheless right so
you have to especially in the context of
like blackface minstrel see right where
people knew what they were seeing but
they wanted to see it anyway right they
paid to be sort of fooled
each night I think we have to leave that
possibility open that that people were
that not only the managers and promoters
but the the audiences that was what was
interesting to them about what they were
seeing I think for some though and this
this is true of when you think about
museums at the time which are not like
museums that we think of today right
they're not places where we go and look
at objects these were sort of more like
theaters where there would be a whole
host of different kinds of things going
on at these museums there was an
interest especially in the east and
going to see Indians and museums because
of the perception that they were a
vanishing race right this idea that you
this might be your last chance to really
see a true authentic Indian so I like to
keep the possibility open to that for
some people they weren't in on the joke
and they thought they were actually
going to see a Choctaw flutist who this
might be their last chance to actually
witness some
of the dying race yeah by the same token
right people may be interested in seeing
basically somebody who's a lot safer I
mean the Indians were perceived as being
fierce and warlike so you could see some
guy in a show like this you may you may
feel better that he's not really a real
Indian yeah yeah absolutely well I mean
I think that part of what their show
hinged on was this idea that they were
Christianized Indians right they've made
a lot of appearances at temperance
events and stuff where they talked about
promoting sobriety and promoting I mean
they they always were trying to raise
money to either promote sobriety or to
promote Christianisation of the Indians
now I have no evidence that any of that
money ever made its way to any missions
or temperance organizations but but yes
absolutely I mean they certainly were
not going to get up there and and make
threatening gestures right or or make
strong statements about native rights
they were playing on this notion of the
noble savage not these sort of ignoble
savage
yeah so could you talk a little bit
about the research particularly on the
the like in that the LDS side side of
things you know we know that these
archives are not necessarily open in the
same way that like the National Archives
is open to researchers did you talk a
little bit about how that part of the
research was sure absolutely so one of
the things that really surprised me was
when I went out to Salt Lake City to the
LDS Church History Library to do some
research as soon as I got there
everybody knew who William Meharry was
right nobody knew who he was but
everybody knew who William Meharry was
because of this this narrative that he
was the one that caused the band that
caused Brigham Young to announce the ban
on blacks in the priesthood in 1847 and
this is a huge issue in church history
right this this idea of blacks not being
a Blackman not being able to attain the
priesthood so part of what was
challenging for me was not so much the
closed nature of the archive but kind of
getting beyond that received wisdom to
figure out what actually was the nature
of these people's relationships to other
Mormons at the time
one thing that's that's very helpful is
that the Mormons of the 19th century
were very prolific in in more ways than
one and they created lots and lots of
documents so there are at various
institutions and organizations primarily
in Utah there are all of these efforts
underway to digitize and make available
make searchable and accessible to
researchers all of these Overland Trail
Diaries write all different kinds of
documents about the experiences at
winter quarters of the experiences in
Nauvoo and Kirtland and I found no
barriers to my access to any of that
information only when I started to poke
into things like patriarchal blessings
which are which are for some people
something that should be closed to
researchers because it's it's given from
elders to to people in the church and is
deemed very kind of personal sort of
document or experience or baptismal
records
so when I was trying to find out whether
Lucy Stan was rebaptised and
vilandra entered the church but you know
that's the sort of thing you would
expect to find in any sort of sort of
religious history adventure I think but
the amount of information that I got
from the Mormon sources far outweighs
those moments where I ran into a closed
door and that was incredible I mean I
even was able to research the material
about her divorce from her first husband
using records from Illinois that had
been put on microfilm and lived in a
family history library in Salt Lake City
right it's as part of one of the sort of
consequences of the ongoing effort of
the church to document all kinds of
things about genealogy is that they have
access to and then provide access to an
incredible amount of information that
you would never imagine has anything to
do with the church in fact really
doesn't except insofar as it might
connect to their members and the
descendants of their members yep I'm
speaking of sacred temple records and
things like that do you happen to know
if her children
arranged for her to be sealed to any of
her earthly husband's after her death I
do not know I don't know I don't know
very much about what happens to the
family after her death with the
exception of just a few kind of pieces
of information here and there but now I
didn't really poke very much further
into into figuring that out yeah I was
contacted by the descendants of one of
her of Samara which was really
fascinating because here you are as a
historian kind of late you think you're
sort of laboring alone in the dark
somewhere no one knows what you're doing
and then suddenly you get an email from
someone saying I heard you're writing
about this person and I'm actually a
real relative but I didn't think to ask
that question I'm not sure if they would
have answered if I had asked it yeah the
the discovery of that her daughter had
adopted a Paiute
boy which was not uncommon particularly
uncommon in the valley at that time
right so during these missions to the
Lamanites in the Great Basin there were
sort of often these situations where the
Utes in particular would offer Indian
children to the Mormon missionaries and
for sale or for exchange and the Mormon
missionaries not wanting to take them as
slaves which is the sort of situation in
which they existed among the Utes would
sometimes say no we're not gonna we
don't want them we don't we don't
believe in slavery we don't want to take
that child and historian Paul Reeve has
talked about in some of those cases than
the Utes would turn around and kill one
of the children and say now you're going
to take one because if you don't take
one I'm gonna kill another one so they
kind of put them in this very difficult
as you can imagine situation where they
were then taking these children back but
it seems clear that many of the young
Native children